If I had been doing it for the money was a grifter.
And I remember this moment when I became aware that my thoughts and opinions
were different than most of my peers. And I was like,
Oh, I need to make a choice.
I either need to just be honest or I can,
I'm smart enough to be able to just pair it,
the talking points and be like dirt Porter. You know,
Trump is prefer and they say that over a million
retweets, just that would be grifting from, for me,
that would be a Griff.
This is the Rubin report. And according to the deep state, I'm Dave Rubin,
a quick reminder guys, subscribe to our YouTube channel,
which gives you just a teeny tiny chance of actually seeing our videos.
All right, then joining me today is a writer,
a comedian and host of the dumpster fire right here on YouTube.
Bridget. Fetisi welcome back to the Rubin report. All right,
lady. You're back. Last time I had you on here, you were at the,
uh, the beginning of your political evolution.
You were saying, I don't know what's going on with this world.
You were trying to make some sense of the world. I still have no idea. Well,
a year later or whatever, it's been barely.
A year, barely a year.
You're one of a, you know,
you're on the shortlist of people that make some sense to me. So, uh,
what does that say about me?
Hey, that's terrifying. People say this to me and I'm like,
you know, that, that the world has gone crazy.
I've somehow I'm a voice of reason. And I get a lot of,
so I guess what's happened is it's true. It has been kind of an exponential,
I guess, um, just from like a statistical point of view and numbers,
point of view on something like Twitter, it has been exponential rise or growth.
And with that comes a lot of criticism
and different criticism, mean things to you.
I know it's strange. I know that this doesn't affect other people,
but it really seems to me predict no,
but I feel like the criticism I get all the time is I'm a grifter, you know,
like I'm some, like I was one way,
and then now I'm another way grifting, but they're like, you know,
eventually you're going to need to knock off this, both sides, routine yards,
because you're always trying to just, I'm like, I'm just being me though.
I'm really confused.
Do you think that that's sort of,
what's working for you more than anything else? Like there's an there, well,
there's just an upfrontness about your evolution. Like for me,
something like five years ago, I just started saying, ah, guys, I'm a liberal,
but something ain't right around here. And then it was just,
people started going, Oh, me too. And I,
I sense sorta like just constantly in that thing
was like, Hey, my pleasure. Thank you.
But I think the difference between, um,
us is that you are already kind of in the political world.
And what was your degree in political science. Okay. So yeah.
I'm one of three people that ever used a political science degree.
You went to college. I dropped out. So.
I was, yeah, but.
I was blacked out and smoking a lot of pot and waitressing.
And I say this to people a lot that I, I, you know,
I talked about the factory settings and how I think when you're just,
when you have your head down and I didn't know until maybe, uh,
maybe last February,
how I was going to pay more than two months worth of bills ever since when I was
17. So when you have your head down, just trying to figure that stuff out,
you're not really paying attention to the anything else. Yeah.
I was just trying to make money and wait tables and I moved to LA so that I
could be a content creator. I wanted to write television shows and do comedy.
And I didn't, I was never,
I was not aware there was a culture war going on,
which sounds completely naive of me. And Michael malice has said to me,
you know, that just goes to show you how, how,
how entrenched the cathedral is in terms of media and
entertainment and academia is that I didn't even know I was in the cathedral.
Right. Do you sense that, uh,
getting the criticism of grifter or somehow you're doing this for money,
even though, as you said,
it's just literally a year and a half ago or you're like, you know,
scrounging around and all that. And also, you know,
it's also funny cause people think just because like we're on YouTube and we
have a little powder on our faces that we're like rolling in dough and it's
like, I'm not complaining by any stretch. And it was a long time to get here.
You know what I mean? I want it.
And I'm just somewhere on my journey as you are. Um,
but I find that this thing of like,
cause a lot of people in our space now get thrown with grifter or you're doing
it for the money or you're a seller or something like that. And in a weird way,
while that used to bother me, now it's becoming, you know,
in some ways it's the ultimate compliment because it's almost like they have
nothing left.
Like there's nothing left about the ideas that you put forth or the positions
that you hold because you actually hold a lot of mixed bag of sort of left right
positions, which I think most people would do.
All they got is actually she's doing it for the money as in money as if you were
like, Oh, if I just stuck out that position over there, you know,
that's where the money rules.
Had been doing it for the money and was a grifter.
And I remember this moment when I became aware that my thoughts and opinions
were different than most of my peers. And I was like,
Oh, I need to make a choice.
I either need to just be honest or I can,
I'm smart enough to be able to just pair it,
the talking points and be like director, you know.
That's hilarious when they say that over and over tweets, just.
That would be grifting from, for me, that would be a grift because for,
I, my idea of a grift is that I'm not being, I'm being disingenuous.
I'm being dishonest. I'm saying that I have one thing and I'm selling another,
but I'm selling my, if I'm selling anything, it's my confusion.
Wouldn't a grift. Also be that you would,
you would take the easier way out like you would like clearly I think,
I think the people that are in the space that we're in,
whatever you want to call that, like this is the road less traveled. Right?
But like, if you're on the grift, you don't do the hard thing.
You do the easy thing.
Yeah. It would be easy for me to go in either direction, all in.
And it would also be easy for me to completely just de defect and be like,
I'm Mackinac.
And I've.
Always joked that there are these two strains of Trump derangement syndrome and
I can quit like pretty quickly tell if somebody has one or the
other it's if everything is Trump's fault or Trump can do no wrong and it's
Magen resistance. So it's like the hashtags and they are,
and I feel like most people exist in the gray area in between,
but they, they get so bombarded by both sides,
if they dare to be like, well, I think there might be, you know,
I can see this from both sides or there might be a perspective here that they
just are like, nah, I'm not, I'm just going to be quiet.
So speaking of that, it's a good reason to have you on now,
because I know you're an expert in foreign policy, especially,
especially related to Iran, right? That's your specific expertise.
Here?
No, that obviously is not true,
but actually often in the morning when I wake up and I have in my coffee and I'm
just sort of like slowly getting online and I'm trying to get my thoughts
centered, I'll shoot you some tax and we'll go back and forth a little bit.
And one of the things over the last couple of weeks that like consistently comes
up is like the craziness related to every single
person on Twitter. But I don't want to make this just about Twitter,
but like the need for all the celebrities, all of the journalists, you know,
air quote, journalists,
and just everybody to have to have a opinion on everything at
all times. Remember, I mean, just a couple of weeks, just a couple weeks ago,
we were in world war II, world war three, go for you.
I walked my dog.
That's the crazy thing. And, and we kind of talked about this on dumpster fire,
my YouTube show, which just makes fun of my whole thing with dumpster fires.
Like we just want to laugh while the world burns because in the moment when news
is breaking and having it is diplomacy by Twitter now, so there,
there is serious, you know,
are there's news breaking the president's tweeting, uh,
a flag then that the ambassador to the Supreme leader is tweeting.
They're flat. These are, I mean, my roommate, Samantha said it perfectly.
She said, it's Ender's game meets risk redder.
It's like.
Perfect description. And I think that there,
so there is this real people are getting hurt. People are affected by this.
It's all playing out virtually.
And then you close your computer or put your phone down and walk outside.
And it's like, dude, they didn't do to do nothing's going on.
And the majority of people have no idea. They're not like living in that.
But if you're in that moment and the news cycle is it's all breaking and
everybody's got their takes and the journalists are all trying to figure it out.
And they're waiting for the Pentagon to confirm things so that they can confirm
the rumors. They're heard it. You get that kind of rush.
Can you make of these people that literally something happens now and then
they have the exact opposite reaction because it was another administration five
years ago.
I'm not talking about somebody that's evolved over time with their political
ideas. I'm talking about while Trump didn't have congressional authorization.
And then there's literally five years ago,
their tweet when they were completely for Libya. I mean,
Nancy Pelosi is a great example. Trump didn't need,
I don't even mean just the people in politics, but there's a video right now.
That's been going around that I've shared of Pelosi five years ago or whatever
it is six years ago saying Trump didn't or Obama didn't need congressional
authorization. We toppled the maybe in regime and Kadafi now he needs it. Like,
but then everyone just flips on every little thing because it's all,
it's all sports.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about comedy,
instead of the nonstop yelling, you get everywhere else,
check out our comedy playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist,
they're both right over here to get notified of all future videos.
Be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.